so this talk is creating the right
developer Community for your company
which changes depending on what you're
looking for and what you need and how
old your community is
so hopefully this will be a nice
interactive talk so if you have
questions feel free to interrupt me I am
here to make sure that this is as clear
and concise and that you get the
information you need to be successful
with community community is a passion of
fine
um
my name is Wesley Faulkner I've been
doing community for a very long time
I've done it for startups I've done it
for large Enterprises I've done it for
non-profits I've done it for temporary
projects and I've done it for rehashing
or re-hauling long existing communities
that need a revamp so I've done every
different kind of iteration of community
but there's still tons out there more
being developed every single day and
hopefully I can bring some of that
experience to you I have at the bottom a
list of logos that kind of like show
that hey I'm Legit but one thing that
you might look up is where I currently
work which is the company AWS Amazon web
services one thing I want to start off
at the very very top I'm here as an
independent actor I'm not here to
represent the company none of my content
none of my views is representing the
company
so I know this is a vendor heavy
conference but I'm actually not
representing any vendors at this moment
just myself
so consider everything I say is agnostic
and not really relevant to my current
role or my current position
clear
all right good
um I want to start off just to figure
out where you are in your community
journey and also this track is for
developer relations and community so I'm
gonna do a poll slash quiz just to see
what you've absorbed over the the couple
two days that you've been here
so
raise your hand if you know what
developer marketing is
okay all right I see about seven Max
hands
uh raise your hand if you know what
developer relations Is
okay more hands okay that's about 10 12
dozen uh raise your hand if you know
what a developer Advocate is
okay well
seven hands again
all right
here's the coup d'etat
um what
raise your hand if you know what a
community manager is
okay all right awesome so let me go over
these terms because I would like for you
to understand how this fits related to
all these other terms like in the
company in your company or if you've
heard it in some of the talks you've
been in or someone you might go to so
developer marketing
what's the difference between developer
marketing and regular marketing
um one has developer in front of it
um but that's the the but the fact is
developers are a little different than
other people developers don't really
understand or
feel like they can relate to General
marketing because General marketing is
for
it's more for bespoke not sorry for more
for like um General things that people
can easily change in and out so if you
want a new toilet paper maybe you'll
fall for General marketing because if
you don't like it you just don't use it
anymore you switch to something else but
developers they choose to get their
tools and their systems in a way that is
like a well-oiled machine
uh just like if you know someone who's
buying a car they're like I like the
color I'm gonna buy that but then you
know someone who's a gear head and they
will open up the manual they will see
about the
um how
how the maintenance of the vehicle is
what kind of Parts it uses
what configuration the engine is to
figure out if they have to change the
the clutch or they have to change out a
piston what they need to do to get to
that part so because if it goes bad they
want to be able to fix it themselves
they want to know how often they need to
rotate the tires what kind of spark
plugs it uses all of the stuff and
developers are more towards the gear
Head side rather than the person who
likes a pretty car because it sparkles
in the sunlight the reason for that
why you have these specific developer
marketing as opposed to marketing is
because if you say we're the fastest if
you say we're the best
that's more generalized
when you talk to an engineer and say
we're the fastest they'll say fastest or
what
we're the quickest win
under what conditions what data load all
of that stuff so it's all the the pins
answer is where you're coming from when
you're talking about developer marketing
and so you have to know your audience
and so it's a specialty of being the
right amount of technical to be able to
present and encapsulate the type of
marketing that will appeal to the
developer mindset
does that make sense is that clear I
know I use a lot of words and stuff
um next let's talk about developer
relations so when you hear developer
relations you think sometimes if you
know what developer relations are that
they sometimes are underneath marketing
sometimes they're not sometimes they're
under product sometimes they're under
the CTO it all depends on what you need
the person to do
developer relations is a department and
a developer Advocate is a person that
works under the department
so if you think of a sales organization
A salesperson is under that at work if
you think of a product organization a
product manager
would be under that org it's the same
with the developer Advocate when you
think of an individual that works under
developer relations they work and
develop they are a developer Advocate
now developer Advocates have multiple
jobs uh the but let's go what developer
relations Is developer relations is the
part of the company that actually talk
to the people that use or will use your
product
and if you're trying to figure out okay
that sounds like marketing uh or it
sounds like customer service or if it
sounds like sales
or if it sounds like product exploration
it's like all of those wrapped into one
person
um
anyone seeing James Bond know James Bond
is okay
um so when you watch the James Bond
movie and James Bond is going into
Casino everybody knows James Bond is a
spy but they talk to him they welcome
them in they invite them out to parties
because he's cool they relate to him
they are able to speak the same language
I'm not going to say to all developer
Advocates are like James Bond just the
ones in front of the mics
um
but what you do is you find someone
who's able to ingratiate themselves with
the community ingotiates themselves with
the people and be able to speak their
language so that they tell them stuff
they say oh your product sucks or your
product is great here or we're running
into some problem and then they from the
outside they really seem like they know
how to have those conversations with
people and they take that learning bring
it into the company talk to products
saying we need to make these changes
talk to customer service saying we need
to fix this part talk to the people who
run the UI and say we need to move this
button or change the color they are the
ones who are able to kind of bring
the the abstract data like if you're
looking at you know graph goes up you
need to know why you need to know what
is the thing that makes it do that and
that's what a developer Advocate does
and developer Advocates have several
different jobs they can write blog posts
they can give speeches and talks at
conferences they can do live streams on
Twitch they can be on YouTube and Tick
Tock they could write documentation they
can do whatever it is where it's a touch
point between the company and the users
and a community manager is a person that
is a developer advocate in developer
relations optimally and then in the
community manager would make sure that
they embrace the people who are using
the product or use or can use the
product but group them together in a way
that makes them sticky around your
company or organization or a product
and this is kind of what that talks
about
so
clearest mud
so that's a lot
um and now that we understand what
developer relations is what developer
Advocate does and what developer
marketing is you can understand how they
all kind of fit together they all work
with each other someone in a community
manager someone who's a community
manager might reference developer
marketing to say oh here's a spec sheet
here is a white paper someone they could
talk to another developer Advocate
saying oh we'll change that
documentation or add that exception or
here's a code snippet you can run
and the reason why
you need a technical community manager
in devrel is because you still want them
to be able to relate to the people
they're talking to
all right
I know that's a lot it's a big Preamble
but let's get to the meat of this stuff
let's talk about Community but let's
talk about what's not a community
so I'm sure everyone here knows what a
community is or heard that term but let
me tell you what a community is not
the reason why this is important is
because a lot of people hear the word
Community just like they hear the word
I don't know love
and they said oh yeah I know love uh
I've experienced love or I'm part of a
community or
um sure that's interesting send that to
the community or let's go talk to the
community and so these are ways that
I've heard them misused but this is only
part of the story
and I will get to that later but let's
talk about why these are not community
and in themselves a forum
a forum is not necessarily a community
because usually a form where you stick
your your facts and your knowledge or
people ask questions and people get
their questions asked
so if you've ever
like gone to Google and you say how do I
do this and then you get a result are
you experiencing community
no but you're experiencing a service
that gets you what you want which is the
answer to your question and that's what
a lot of forms are how many users can I
use what what can I do with the API or
has anyone seen this problem they care
about the answer getting the answer and
then getting out the communities aren't
just a knowledge base they are an
experience so that's why a forum in
itself if you set it up it's not a
community
social media
have you ever heard of someone say hey
let's tweet that the community will love
that
or let's put that on social that's the
community will eat this up or this is
something that they need to know
I'm sure several of us here are on
social and several of us here follow
companies but do you yourself consider
yourself part of their community
um I I mean you might hear or be
interested what they're saying but
you're not having that back and forth
with them in which you're having a
conversation and if they said hey this
is
new inversion 5.x97
you might under might use that
information you might even say hey
that's cool but do they say yeah it's
cool back to you no there's no
conversation and because it's one way
it's a broadcast channel for most
companies
that type of social is not a community
it's a it's a megaphone it's like any
other advertising at that point
same with YouTube If you go to YouTube
and there is a monthly dispatch or
they're saying like here's uh an update
and this is for the community
that in itself is not a community
because once again it's a broadcast are
they reading the comments are they
answering questions are they responding
if they're not doing any of the things
that show that they're actually
listening to you
it's not a community
so if you are in a space and they say
let's make this video the community
demands it just realize that it's not
necessarily an action or the the people
you're speaking to may not be considered
your community
and last but not least I hear this all
the time
sometimes people think that paying
customers are a community
I would hopefully
um hopefully this is like the easiest
one but this is one that gets confused
the most uh everyone's wearing clothes
right
okay
all right some of you are wearing brands
I'm guessing you're not part of the
community for every single brand
that you buy if you stop at a gas
station are you part of that Community
or if you get fast food are you part of
that Community how many of you use
Amazon or do you consider yourself part
of the Amazon community I mean it's in a
lot of companies think just because
someone's a customer they're part of the
community and that is not true
whatsoever there it's just a transaction
Community involves deeper deeper
involvement
um has anyone heard that before
okay
um
the reason why I want to emphasize this
is because Community is a dictionary
term you can look up in the dictionary
the word community and you can get
several different answers and people
will see it like a Rorschach test of
saying that's Community because they
don't really understand the meaning of
the word
Community can be as small as two people
or as big as the whole entire world
and so if you're working in community or
if you're thinking about being in a
community or starting a community or
describing your own Community you need
to make a definition of what's in and
what's out
all right let's move to the next section
where we're talking about now we know
what's not in a community let's talk
about what's the ingredients for a good
successful community and the reason why
I'm moving to this from that is you can
see how the the previous examples do not
have this okay
peer-to-peer interaction
are people themselves talking amongst
themselves
in the first example with the Forum
people might be responding to a query
but that is less of an interaction and
more of a transaction that's people not
really relating from a point of
deepening their understanding of each
other this is just getting the
information
if you've ever heard the difference
between uh
like going to a restaurant or getting a
home-cooked meal those are different
transactions one's for money one's for
care and feeding
next is a clear core interest
when you think about some of those
Outlets like social media someone's like
I'm not just on
Instagram just to talk to you they're on
Instagram to talk to everyone or to see
their friends pictures or the posts
themselves and so if they are not going
there to seek a technical community if
they're not going there to seek
um uh
uh a data Community or the thing that is
their core their Niche then that is not
necessarily a community
if they go to your Forum that checks
that box right they want to go and
understand how do I use your product
better how do I solve this problem or
what problems other people are having
that I can help solve that is closest to
a community but still because of the
core interest is surfaced but it is not
checking all the boxes
and the and the reason why is individual
expression is listed here
um
I've got several of you probably are
part of some Club
around something
a TV show
um uh religious belief
or a hobby
and what makes those communities special
or the sticky part of it or the thing
that like you go back for to the people
is not because they're just like you
it's because the little things that
cause them to be a little bit different
but you know you have that base level
understanding that you don't have to
cover over and over and over again
um how many of you have problems
explaining what you do for your job when
you meet someone new right uh you got to
figure out what level of distraction
like I was like for me it's like well I
work with uh user groups oh you don't
mind um well I work with Community
um
so I'm in developer relation oh gosh
um so aw have you heard of Amazon
and so I have to figure out like where I
need to go even start that conversation
and like after
um they've fallen asleep I walk away but
uh but it's nice to go to people who you
know and you care for and they care for
you and then you don't have to say oh
God I was on call last week and it was
horrible and they're like and they won't
you know you won't get the question back
what's on call
pager you have a pager no no it's not
it's pagerduty it's like no okay uh
part of a community is not the thing
that
um is what binds you and what brought
you there is the thing that gets you in
the place but keeps you in the place is
the people and their self-expression and
how they show they care and how they
show that they're aligned on other
different interests and how they bring
that into the community
that bring articles that bring posts
that bring XKCD cartoons that shows
exactly what you're dealing with those
are the type of things of
self-expression that make you want to go
back when you are going there
just mindlessly opening up an app or
logging on to a service or bookmarking a
place because you want to go there for
the people
as well as the information and knowledge
that's when you're getting closer to a
community
and that no Community is good without
moderation
I like to explain Community as a big
thick border so that you know who's in
but you also have that border to keep
the other people out and if someone
violates your rules someone evaluates
your trusts someone who is not one of us
anymore there needs to be someone who's
enforcing that it can't be on the
community members because that's awkward
so you need moderation to be able to
define those rules to make sure that
whoever
is is not part of the group anymore that
they get kicked out and also make sure
that not every with Joe schmoe can just
join just because they found you on the
internet you want that moderation to
keep the community healthy without that
check then it could fall into chaos or
someone who's an influencer in that
Community could just take it over and
you don't want that either because
you'll lose power and you lose control
so it's important to have moderation in
a community
okay any questions
all right
I'm assuming every time I say there's
any questions and no one raises their
hand that means I'm doing amazing and I
get 5 out of 5 stars
okay let's talk about the different
kinds of community because that's kind
of the core of the talk like what
communities will suit you let's talk
about the options that are out there
this is not an exhaustive list but this
at least gets you like a baseline of
ones that you might be familiar with and
you also might be instituting or think
about instituting in the near future
um let's talk about the ambassador
program now this is like if you're going
to go all out that's what you need you
want people out there talking about you
without even even telling them they are
your Advocates they're the ones who are
evangelizing you and they're the ones
who are telling their friends hey if
you're not using this I don't know
what's wrong with you
um these this program
uh it's pretty pretty up there
um but it's one that's fairly effective
if you're able to get one going
anyone here heard of Champions programs
or Heroes programs yeah yeah and uh
those are the the people who are out
there not only talking about your
company but in a way they represent your
company so it's important to vet these
people the most
because if you
um you don't want a Jared from Subway
out there representing your company
because it could get messy and then you
have to just to say well how did they
get in did you vet them and you lose the
patina of being being the upper echelon
of the representative of the company
when it feels as if anyone can just go
out there and just say hey I'll talk
about you can I be part of your
ambassador program so it's it's great
visibility but also great liability so
keep that in mind
next is a newsletter everyone are is
probably familiar with the newsletters
you probably got 12 this morning and if
you went into the vendor Booth you might
be getting some more
newsletters are great because they are
sometimes
one person can author that and then it
gets sent to many
the question is or if you remember we
talked about how things are not
community and this is quickly one that
could be on that list but let me tell
you why a newsletter can be a community
if it has that thing that I talk to you
about if there is uniqueness you're
highlighting people from the community
you're bringing them in you're getting
their feedback they're getting asking
questions you're answering those
questions you're highlighting those
specific names you're talking about
their situation people are relating to
that and people feel that they are
getting a push and a pull from the
newsletter if it's just a printing of
this is a newsletter this is what's new
and it just turns into another broadcast
medium which is not what you want so but
if you actually want Community make sure
you have those elements from that I
mentioned before
and I brought up a form before same you
can have a forum and have a community
The Forum is the tool it's the way that
you use it that makes it an actual
Community are you asking what people are
doing are you asking what their problems
are are you saying hey did you have a
good week or are you celebrating
anything during the New Years are you
going to a big party if you're bringing
out that uniqueness in people by
allowing them the space to talk about
that if you have an off topic Channel
all those are different ways that you
can bring forth what the community is
doing if you're in a highly Technical
Community you can ask what are you
working on what are the projects your
tinkering with what are some of the uh
certifications you're going for what
helped you level up to where you are now
being able to help people from the
community by lifting up those can be
that can be an inspiration to others or
someone further in their Journey that
you can point to and say this is the
path that they took and give that help
to other people in the community those
are the type of actions that you want in
a forum
and I mentioned social media and how
it's not a community uh surprise it can
be once again it's a medium not
um it's the tool not just how you use it
not what you use but how you use it so
are you doing the same thing I mentioned
for the newsletters and the forums by
having that give and take
responding to people following people
back hitting like on some of their
messages and their replies those are
ways that you can use social media for
community actions and of course I have
user groups in here because that's kind
of like my bread and butter
um user groups are groups of people that
not only go out there and talk about
your product your service but they bring
people in they give the nice handshake
the warm smile sometimes pizza and a
beer depending on the type of place it's
where people can have a First and
Lasting Impression in the area
physically where they are
there are virtual user groups as well
where people can just gather on a
regular basis once a month once a week
once a quarter same location different
location but if you ever thought about
how you leave like an organization it's
in realizing that it's leaving the
people behind
a user group is a good manifestation of
why people once they switch jobs once
they switch careers they still might
stay in their User Group because they
are there for the community and they
have that shared interest that they go
back to over and over again
and then after a certain amount of scale
with a company you might actually need
to do an internal community
so this is something that people don't
really talk about all that much is that
when you are working at a company and
someone's doing sales for product a and
another one's doing sales for product B
and someone's a product owner for
product C and then someone's doing
customer service product D they have
information that they could share
amongst each other
if you bump into someone
on the way to the bathroom or at the
cafeteria in a virtual world that
doesn't happen as much there's a lot of
return to office politics about saying
that that's something that people are
missing because of where we are in this
remote world but you can still find a
way to bring community in a team outside
the team different departments so that
you can have that Synergy you can have
that same kind of a cohesion
and also information sharing I can't
tell you how many times that I've heard
oh we're watching this product well
we're launching this product we should
work together or we should coordinate
launches or you're working with this
partner and I'm working with this
partner we should get them get together
and we can do an event or we can do some
co-marketing which was mentioned before
all those different things can happen
with an internal Community to make sure
that you can break down some of those
silos those barriers those walls so that
collaborative collaboration can work
better between everyone
okay yes
about me sure
because they've never spoken to you and
that's really helped
within the company and that's a nice way
of doing it without
it being just on the project oh that's
awesome so if you didn't hear she set up
um sorry uh Battleship I presumed your
pronouns is that okay okay
um they set up battleship uh it's really
good example of using a a kind of a
a set of rules and a paradigm that
people can understand and follow rather
than an open-ended kind of network Force
networking where you have icebreakers
where it could be kind of awkward but
understanding
the the pace and understand what the
objective is and people are going
through the motions allow them to not
have that overhead to be able to relate
which is really great and it was opt-in
which is also really great as well
um I have a an internal story of my own
that I did that I will share at office
hours if you if you have more if you
want more information on how to do
internal Community I have a lot of
examples there
um let's talk about these last two and
then we'll move forward slack of course
you've heard of a lot of people spunting
spinning up a slack spinning up a
Discord or some other chat but you still
need to make sure that you allow people
to have some sort of uniqueness meaning
like avatars uh meaning like emojis or
any types of uh memes or the same type
of plugins that allow them to do some
self-expression also make sure that you
set up the channels or default channels
or have it locked down enough that
people can find a way to still Express
themselves given the current guidelines
and the structure of the community so
and then
so the reason why slack is popular is
because it has an infinite kind of user
base if you're on the free plan you just
lose some
um some of the perks and plugins and
retention of data so keep that in mind
that if you are using a slack Community
you cannot necessarily use it as a user
as a database of fixing problems because
those problems will roll back no one
will be able to search for them after a
certain period of time you'll need to
either find a way to
upload that over to another database
that people can use or somehow go for
the paid plan which can be extremely
expensive as you have more users word of
warning and of course there's events uh
yes you have a question
Discord
slack versus Discord is a question
yes
so there's there's two sides of that
answer the reason for that is one you
need to make sure that the user base is
familiar with those tools and then also
the other part of that the person who's
administrating it is you is familiar
with that tool there are people who will
just gravitate to the tool that they are
more comfortable with from the
administration side and that is and this
might be controversial that's okay
because you want someone to not
necessarily have to spend their time
figuring out how to use the tool uh you
want them to be natural and a thing that
they would want to use and it's easier
for them to use if they have to ramp up
on a new tool that they're not familiar
with then that could slow everything
down but if you're in a space where your
users are highly aligned to one tool and
that tool is slack over Discord then you
need to figure out how to start using
slack because that's going to service
the users and there's also a different
approach depending on the maturity of
your user group program because
um you're not necessarily
trying to Encompass everyone that would
be a user in this Outlet you just need
to make sure that you can get started so
you might start off in slack and then do
a Discord and have both but we'll get to
that later but
um
I I first lean on the community if you
have data to support that they are
leaning one to the other second is
whatever tool the moderator or the
community manager is very familiar with
and that would be a strong second and
then of course there's other mitigating
circumstances in terms of
housing it or using a host
and security patches and all this other
stuff that is really complicated and so
all of that from an abstract point of
view needs to be taken in account as
well
all right last one is events uh events
is where you're out there you're meeting
people you're shaking hands kind of like
this
and this is where you can kind of Leap
Forward in terms of uh deepen the
relationship on an accelerated basis
email chat even a video call is great
but a physical event or a virtual event
where you have extended time with
talking to people having dialogue having
some really good sense of what kind of
person you are or what you're about your
values that sort of thing
events are really good way of really
connecting with the community for them
to connect with you because by default
it's a dialogue
uh no one's showing up to a webinar
where it's here only and you're just
listening to Talking Heads at a physical
event you are out there having that
conversation so these are just a
smathering of community but now you've
heard all this stuff but you don't know
how to use it that's totally fine I plan
for that let's talk about where you are
in your community Journey you either
have one or you don't and if you do you
probably fit into one of these three
buckets
um you're either
just starting out you have one person
that's in charge of maintaining this
community that com that person may have
the title of community manager or they
may have the title of community manager
plus which is community planager plus
engineer or customer service or whatever
they're doing a whole bunch of things
because it's either a startup or this is
a brand new position that they're
testing out or even a contractor that
works part-time so if you're just
starting out you're probably going to
have one person sitting there posting
the posts setting up the systems and
then you have your employees
participating because you want to want
it to look active right so then you have
people in there answering questions on
the forums responding back to social
media requests or helping to submit to
the newsletter that's going to go out to
everyone those are all different ways
that you have to leverage the rest of
the company just to even make it
successful and usually you'll probably
be around one maybe two maybe three or
small all handful of different mediums
but you're only going to your primary is
one and then you kind of Syndicate to
the others those are kind of what people
think of when they're just getting
started so this is just a sizing guide
if you're on a medium size then you
might have one or two Community managers
like a a head Community manager and an
assistant Community manager or someone
in charge of Instagram someone in charge
of Twitter someone's on the Forum and
then someone's on Tick Tock or something
like that and then you're you you have
employees helping or liking but they're
not the primary source of some of the
contents and interactions and so you're
kind of fostering that people are
interacting with the community and
helping with answering form requests or
any types of questions or responding to
the comments in the comment section of
the different types of mediums
and then you're able to spread out and
do more more Outlets of community
and then if you're a large organization
organization you're of course going to
have like a whole team of community
managers you're going to have a minimum
employment employee participating it
meaning that they opt into it it's not
something their manager is telling them
to do they then you're able to have all
these different mediums to participate
so you'll have video you'll have audio
you'll have a
still pictures you'll have blog posts
you'll have all the different ways that
you can participate in these communities
so this is just this should help you
figure out where your company is or
where you are
um and you're in one of these and when
you're in a community you're probably
going to need to follow this flow
organically so if you have a ton of
money
don't jump straight here
start here and then grow here because if
you hire all these people and then
you're on all these different mediums
you don't know necessarily which ones
are paying off which ones are worth
investing in and you'll either have like
depreciation meaning like you'll just
stop supporting one of these mediums or
you have a layoff and you'll have to let
someone go and then someone else has to
take on the work even though you're
structured to have them separated and
you're kind of figuring out how to
shrink it's always going to be a little
bit easier to grow through pain rather
than to shrink through pain
so when you are starting
start small before you go large or
crawl walk then run so figure out
how you get your balance
then you can start walking and then you
can start sprinting
and just going back really quickly these
are some of the things that I mentioned
before and I separated them
into the crawl walk run depending on the
expertise and what you're learning about
the community
so social media is going to be a crawl
it's you can start doing broadcast start
responding back to people you can do
your newsletter one person can manage
that and then respond to those in the Q
a section and then highlight people you
can do events because one person can
show up and bring a team of people and
then you just try to have them meet each
other but also you can meet as many
people as you can in the walk you can
have slack but then you're going to have
to have like almost 24 hour notice I
mean sorry visibility you want to be
able to have like somewhat of an SLA for
each of these different things you can
also have larger events with more people
and then once you are able to get the
walk done
then you can move over to the Run side
and you can do that those high level
Ambassador programs like I talked about
you can your company is going to be huge
so now you have to do internal
um internal groups and and communities
so that they're all on the same page
then you have to do user groups because
now you need to scale out your growth to
other people who can bring out those
messages bring other people in and bring
them into the community
those are all different ways that you
can think of just the size of the
community
and figure out how you can map on where
you are based on that trajectory and
then once again you can probably think
about these in different ways like move
over slacks tool across days possibly
but then you have to think about if you
can support it or if that's the medium
or do they need Discord but
understanding where people are
is where you're going to help to see if
these will be successful and you you
intrinsically should know some of this
information as you get started and it's
the reason and you're going to start
making a lot of mistakes in this phase
and then refining and then perfecting as
you go through
okay
where do you start
uh each one of these sections that I
mentioned the crawl walk one run those
are restarting you're going to learn
something with each progression but if
you haven't started already where do you
even get started so how do you even
think about this from Mechanicals
mechanically from the way that you get
started
um you identify your target audience
where are they in the funnel are you
looking to have community members of
people who've never heard of you are you
looking to have community members from
people who are deep in and they want to
level up on their understanding
and think about the cold start problem
all right you have absolutely no
information where do you start how do
you get that information
look at just the signal what are typical
people in that industry doing what are
they using how are they Gathering what
kind of feedback do you get from your
customer base in terms of complaints
people who don't renew who do who does
renew who's sending you proactive
questions without them asking you you
use that to funnel your existing
community
and when you can re you can re-engage
your community if it's like someone has
a Facebook group someone has a LinkedIn
group you can go in there talk to them
and try to go where they are before
having to bring them into
um your own community
and the last but not least
self-selection so make sure when I
talked about that thick border
make sure that's clear about who's in
your community
what what you're targeting and what your
community is for and then allow the
people who find and self-select and
self-identify those values to come into
your community
thank you for your time
foreign